شكرا انه لشرف كبير ان تكوني معنا اليوم
اليوم عشنا في اكثر يوما يتسم بالشر في
تاريخ بلادنا
فلا يمكن ان نتخيل لرئيس سابق ان يتعرض
على يد خصومه لما
عشته اليوم
وهذا ياتي في خضم الانتخابات وسباقات
الرئاسيه
[تصفيق]
هذا ما يسمى
بالتدخل في الانتخابات من اجل سرقتها
والاكثر اهميه
انه اضطهاد سياسي بصوره واضحه من وهو من
خصال الدول الفاشيه الشيوعيه
وهذا اليوم سوف يتم تذكره وسوف يتم تذكر
جو بايدن بصفته عن الرئيس الاكثر فسادا
والرئيس الذي يعيش مع زمره من
الاشخاص الذين يسعون لقتل الديمقراطي
الامريكيه لكنهم سوف يفشلون وسوف يخفقون
ونحن
من سوف يفوز في النهايه
اتهام رئيس سابق للولايات المتحده بموجب
بقانون التجسس لعام 1970
هو امر مثير للصخر وهو قانون
يمكن لا يمكن ان يتم فعله وان يتم تهديد
بالسجن لمده 400 عام فقط لامتلاك بعض
المستندات حاليه حاله للرؤساء الاخرين وهو
تصرف شائن بموجب هذه النظريات الاخيره
التي النظريات القانونيه التي طرحت بموجب
قانوني التجسس الذي كان يطبق على الخونه
والمتجسسين ولا يمكن لان يطبق بحق رئيسا
احتفظ بمسندات
لان هذا القانون لا يمكن قانون التجسس لا
يمكن ان يتم تطبيقه كذلك الحال ايضا
بالنسبه لقانون السجلات الرئاسيه بموجب
التقرير المؤلف من اربعين صفحه
فيجب ان ياتي في خضم قانون مدني يحق
للحفاظ بتلك المستندات
وهذا قد تم توضيحه في اهم القضايا
المعروفه
بقضايا كلينتون
اذا ما احتفظت اذا ما احتفظت كلينتون
عندما غادرت البيت الابيض باكثر من 70 نوع
من انواع المستندات السريه وتحتوي على
قضايا تتعلق بالمعلومات العسكريه والسياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه وكوبا
وهذا هذه المحادثات التي اجريت في عهد
كلينتون مع كافه زعماء الاجانب في ذلك
الوقت وحقائق حساسه حول المفاوضات
التجاريه التي تم الحصول عليها من احاطات
الرئاسيه ومناقشات مع وزراء الخارجيه في
ازمات مثل البوسنه
وحتى انه لم يتم النظر بقضيه اقلينتون
للمقاضات الجنائيه
وعندما تمت محاكمته في بشان هذه القضايا
كسب هذه القضايا القاضي ايمي جين براكسون
ذكر في بموجب الخط القانونيه
بان هذا ياتي بموجب القانون السجلات
الرئاسيه
قانوني فصل لسجلاتي عن الرؤساء يتم من قبل
الرئيس خلال عهده الرئيس وخلال
وبموجب خيار الرئيس بمفرده
انكم مندهشون لسماع ذلك اي اداره عاديه
حتى الادارات المعارضه سوف تعتبر ذلك ان
هذا هو طبيعه الامر لكن ليس اداره بايدن
الفاسده القرار قرار الصادر بحق كلينتون
يلخص
انه لا يجوز
تصنيف هذه المواد على انها مواد ذات طابع
الرئاسيه
وهذا لا يعني انه هناك حق
السلطات بان تقوم بمصادرتها ولا يمكن
السلطات القضائيه ان تقوم بمنفرده بطريقه
غير مقيده بالاتخاذ هذا القرار
بالمقابلتين حتى
الجهات الارشيفيه حتى ايضا الكونجرس لا
يجوز له ان يطعن بقرار الرئيس
فلا يمكن ان يتم منحي اي سلطات
لجهات الارشيف بتصنيف المستندات وبموجب
القانون كانت هذه المسؤوليه التي تختص
بالرئيس لوحده برئيس الولايات المتحده هذا
هو القرار فكروا به
بمعنى اخر
بصرف النظر عن الوثائق التي يقرر الرئيس
الاحتفاظ بها فهو فهو له الحق بكل ذلك هذا
هو صلب القانون
وهي مساله
الان اطلع عليها الناس وباتت اكثر وضوحا
وعليهم ان يسقطوا هذه القضيه والدعاء
الموجهه ضد فورا
ولهذا سبب ما من رئيس اخر حتى اولئك الذين
احتفظوا بمستندات اكثر مني
تمت تم التحقيق معهم فضلا عن توجيه التهم
الجنائيه لهم لان
ما فعله الرئيس بايدن
ومقاموا به من مداهمات لمنزل كانت توجد
لدي الصناديق تلك لماذا ترغبون بالحصول
عليها الاجابه هي انه بموجب قانون السجلات
الرئيسيه في هذا من حق فهي تحتوي على جمله
من
الاغراض الشخصيه بما في ذلك قمصان وما
شابه ذلك يمكنكم ان تطلعوا على هذه
الصناديق
التي كانت ملقاه
على الارض تحتوي على
الصحف والاف من الصور الخاصه بالبيت
الابيض
وبعض مصورين البيت الابيض موجودون معنا
اليوم التقطوا صورا كثيره ووضعوا تلك
الصور في هذه الصناديق وملابس وبعض
الاشياء التذكاريه وغيرها
لم تكن لي فرصه
للاطلاع على كافه المحتويات هذه الصناديق
لك لانه لدي حياه مليئه بالمشغل وقد
جعلوها اكثر انشغالا
وبموجب القرار الصادر بقضيه كلينتون يبدو
بانه ما من عجله ابدا
لان ذلك القرار كان ينم
عما يسمونه القانون بعدما ان قاموا بدفع
اف بي اي بشن مداهمه على منزل في مارلجو
ووضعوا تلك الصناديق ملقاه على الارض
تتذكرون تلك الصور
وكان يفترض ان تكون تلك صناديق هناك
بعد ان تمت مداهمه بعد ان تمت مداهمتها
وقد قاموا باطلاقه
باصدار تلك الصور للصحافه
واعبثوا بمستندات الخاصه او حتى شهدت
الميلادي ولم يعتذروا
وقد قاموا ايضا بالوصول الى خزنه الخاصه
ولم يعتروا على اي شيء فيها
ووفقا لقانون السجلات الرئاسيه
كان يفترض بي ان اتفاوض معهم وهذا ما قمت
به الى حين تمت مداهمتي
كانت توجد لدي اشرطه امنيه عن تلك
المداهمات
وهذا يشكل انتهاكا صارخا للدستور الذي
يحمي
الحق من اجراء اي تفتيش غير معقول او اي
عمليات اي عمليه ضبط غير معقوله
انت غطيت هذا الامر
انا لست بالشخص الذي يعتقد بانه فوق
القانون بل انا حالي حال الاخرين
انه جو بايدن
وحلقته المقربه من وزاره العدل الفاسدين
الذين هم فوق القانون لم ارى معيارا
مزدوجا وكيلا بمكيالين للعداله كما نعيشه
الان لقد اختار جو بايدن
الحصول على بعض المستندات السريه عندما
كان سيناتورا وهذا غير قانوني لا يحق
للسنتور الحصول عليها هل سمعتم عن هذا
الامر هل شاهدتم رده
كيف يمكن لسنتر ان يقوم بالاستحواذ
بالاستحواذ على تلك المستندات وقد صدموا
عندما
تم وقد كانت هناك صدمه انه تم التوصل الى
اكثر من 1850 صندوق من المستندات في جامعه
الدول تم نقلها الى هناك ورفض تسليمها
ورفض ايضا السماح الى الناس بالنظر اليها
ولا يمكنكم ان تصوروا ذلك ومجموعه كبيره
من المستندات السريه الخاصه تتعلق بتشاينا
تاون
وهو امر صادم ويظهر حجم الاموال الكبيره
التي تم تلقيها من الصين كيف لنا ان نتخيل
ما قام به بايدن من حصوله على هذه الاموال
من شان وكذلك ايضا مركز تشن بايدن في
واشنطن الذي يتم تلقي من خلاله ملايين
الدولارات
حتى ان مجموعه من هذه
المستندات موجوده في كراجي منزل
التلاعب واقامه
مجموعه من الفضائح التي كانت مكشوفه حول
حول افعالها غير القانونيه والمشروع حتى
ولعلكم تذكرون
الكمبيوتر الخاص بانتوني وان والمحتوى
الذي تم العثور عليه
لحسن الحظ لم تكن رئيسه انذاك ولم تمتلك
الصلاحيات
لم تكن
لم تكن رئيسه
وكذلك لم يكن الان ذاك رئيسا للاحتفاظ
بتلك المسانده
عيد ميلاد سعيد
[موسيقى]
انه عيد ميلاد سعيد اليس كذلك
[تصفيق]
كنت مع اركبوا
احفادي وكانوا يغنون اغنيه
يعبرون فيها عن امنياتهم بعيد ميلاد سعيد
لكننا سوف نصل الى عيد الميلاد الاكبر
بالنسبه لنا جميعا
عندها قامت هيلر كلينتون بحذف مجموعه
كبيره من الرسائل الالكترونيه اكثر من 33
الف ايميل كلها قد اختفت رغم
التحقيق وقررت بعد ذلك ان تقوم بتدمير
هواتفها المتحركه بمصرفة
ولم يقل عنها بانها عملت على عرقله
العداله فما من عرقله للعداله فاضحه كما
قامت به هيلر كلينتون اذ قامت بصوره فاضحه
بهذه التصرفات والاف بي اي ووزاره العدل
عملوا على حمايه الاعداء ووزاره العدل
العامله على حمايتها ولم يقدموا بحقها اي
مذكره استدعاء
وجيمس كولمي من قال بانه ما من سبب يدفعه
لمقاضتها بصوره معقوله
هذا مجرد هذا ايضا من فيض هيلر كلينتون
خالفت القانون ولم توجه اليها لواحتها
خلف القانون
بطرق كثيره وحتى اللحظه
لم توجه اليه لائحه التامه اما انا ففعلته
الصواب ولا مع ذلك فوجهوا لواحي اتهام حيث
كنت مثلا يحتذى به
قضيه
بلكلينتون
مستشار امن القانوني الذي كان يسرق مسندات
من الارشيفات الوطنيه
ويضعها في بنطاله عندما يخرج وكان يقوم
بتدمرها وتلفها
وما فعله برجر من
انذاك كان غير قانوني لكن لم يتعرض لعقوبه
السجن
هناك امثله اخرى
الذي قد يصعب تصديقي ما فعله انني كنت على
علاقه جيده
كان كان
يجدر ان يستخدم كمستشارا في انتخابات عام
وانا ذاك تقدم بنصح لي قال لي لا تترشح
لانك سوف تخسر
جورج دبليو بوش
عهده تم فقدان اعداد كبيره من السجلات
والمعلومات المهمه
وكانت محمله
علمتني حافله متوجهه الى منزله
وكذلك الحال بالنسبه
لاكلينتون التي حصلت على
على فرش فاخر
بمئات الالاف من الدولارات
ماذا لو فعل ترامب كل هذه الامور
الانتهاكات الصارخه لحقوق من قبل الكاذب
لا يمكن قبولها في ظل مقام به بتوجيه
وزاره العدل
الديمقراطيون كلهم
قاموا
بفعل عمل شائن
لمحامينا بشكل عام في البلاد لقد
جعلوهم بحاله من الانقسام
عمليه تسريب المستندات كانت
خارج حدود التصور فقد علمنا هذا الامر من
الواسطه بوست من وزاره العدل عن الصناديق
التي كانوا يحتفظون بها
هل تختارون الواشنطن ام نيويورك تايمز
للاطلاع على تلك الحقائق
لا يفترض الامر ان يسير على هذا النحو نود
ان نتعلم من
الاشخاص الذين يجب ان نعرف منهم بصوره
مباشره
لكننا لم نعلم اي شيء عن خططي رشا بايدن
وتحقيقات
الذي كان شخصا يحظى باحترام وتقدير كبيره
هو
احيانا
الامر نفسه ينطلع على ويليام بار الذي لم
يستطع التوصل الى اي شيء
واشار حينها الى
امتلاكي مايك بعض المستندات ما تم ما تمت
تبرئته
فهذه سابقه لا يمكن تصورها
المدعي العام
سميته
سميته بانه
الذي
بانه شخص يعمل خلف سجلات لكن
سجله مروع
فهو
يعرف عنه بانه يقوم باعتقال بعض الحكام
بصوره بشعه مثل
باب ماكدونالدز في فرجينيا واثر على على
اسرته وعلى حياتهم
واحيلت قضيته الى المحكمه العليا ولم ينجم
عن ذلك اي شيء سوى تدمير حياه ذلك الرجل
لكن اقول لكم انني انا هنا واحبكم جميعا
[تصفيق]
لكن هؤلاء المجرمون
وما فعلوه لاسرتي هو عار كبير واقول هذا
الامر لكافه الوسائل الاعلاميه المضلله
ما فعله لاسره ولهذا الشاب هناك
قد يكون
وقعه اكثر من كافه مذكرات الاستدعاء
التي
اثرت عليه بسبب هؤلاء الموجودين في
الكونغرس
وبعدما قدموا كل مذكرات الاستدعاء لكن
اريك هذا هو ابني هنا
وايفانكا ما قدموه وفلوه
ينم عن جديتهم
لكن الاثر الذي تم
الذي خلفوه على اسرتي كان كبيرا
من غير
المدهش ان نرى ان هؤلاء المجانين سوف
يقومون بعقد تلك المحاكمات دون ان ينتبهوا
ان يعيروا اي اهتماما للدستور او لسياده
القانون
اذا ما نظرتم
الى هذا الرجل فهو يبدو بالمجرم
ويشعر
بالامان عندما يقوم بتقديم تصريحات من
داخل وزاره العدل فهو
يبدو بانه
الذي
ينظم لكل هذه الحمله
التي تسمى
تذكروا ان
هذه
الحملات تتم من قبل نفسي الهيئه الحكوميه
التي تم
بالتي قامت
بتقديم تلك الفضائح بدءا من تدخل
بروسيا ومن ثم
طلباتي العزل الاول والثاني ومن ثم حمله
المعلومات الروسيه المظلله
والتي
وفق والتي قد تمت من 17 الى 20 جهه راسيه
ومع ذلك حصلنا على اكبر نسبه تصويت
بالمقارنه مع رؤساء الاخرين وكذلك فعلت
ابليت بلاء حسنا في الانتخابات الثانيه
اكثر من الانتخابات الاولى وماذا بشان
الملفات الزائفه
لم يكن الامر بتلك السهوله
اتجسس على حمله الانتخابيه
والاف بي اي
قاموا
بشن حمله من المعلومات الكاذبه والمضلله
من اجل حمايه الراديكاليين اليساريين
وليس من المصادفه ان هذه التهم ضدي قد
جاءت في نفس اليوم الذي
ظهرت فيه ادله عن حصول جو بايدن على رشا
بقيمه 5 مليون دولار لكنه وزاره العدل لم
ترغب ايضا بالاشاره الى هذا الامر
ولم تعرض حتى على بعض الشبكات الاخباريه
لكن محاوله العزل فقد تمت تغطيتها ببرامج
اخباريه متعدده مده كل منها لا تقل عن
ثلاث ساعات
اقول لكم بانني لم اشهد نفس هذا القدر من
الحب
في ميامي كما رايته اليوم لانهم كلهم
يدركون ما مررنا به من معضلات
فاناس كثر قد جاءوا
من
من مناطق اخرى من كوبا وفنزويلا وراوا هذه
الامور تحدث
في بلدانهم واقول لكم بانه اذا بلادي
استمرت في هذا المسار فسوف تصبحوا مثل
فنزويلا او كوبا
اننا
اننا نقوم
بشراء القطران الاسوا
من هذه البلدان ونعمل على تنقيتها
لابد من العمل على تخفيض الضرائب في
المستقبل
لكنهم يبدو بان الاداره الحاليه تعمل على
تبديد الانظار من
تبديد النظر عن الوقاء عن الوقائع التي
يعيشها
بايدن في ظل فضائح الرشه التي يتعرض لها
واحد علمي ان هناك سبعه عشر شريطا مسجلا
تثبت تقاضيه للرجال
لكن لا تظهر تلك الاشرطه تتذكروا انهم
قاموا بعزل فقط لطرح سؤال عن تورط بايدن
في اوكرانيا وكنت محقا
جو بايدن واليسار المتطرف يتلقون رشا
اجنبيه وهم محميين بالكامل
وعليكم ايها الجمهورين ان تكونوا اكثر
قساوه وصلابه عندما تقوم باعتقال
زعيمكم
الجمهوري فهذا يعني طفولا للديمقراطيه
وخاصه في ظل ما تعيش بلادنا من ويلات
عندما يسمح للتضخم بالارتفاع الى هذه
المساويات
وبعد تخلينا عن استقلاليتنا في الطاقه
التي عشنا بها لفتره طويله
فليبدو باننا سوف نقوم بتبديد كافه اموال
دافع الضرائب بطريقه لم تعشها البلاد
عندما يتم سلب كذب كافه هذه الامور وعندما
يتم رفع الضرائب
بصوره كبيره ويسمح للمجرمين والقتل
الخاطرين بالتجول في شوارعنا
دون ان تقوم السلطات القضيه بفعل اي شيء
كل ما تفعله هو توجيه لوائح اتهامات
ويقولون انه ما من جرائم موجوده هناك
اذا ما نجى الشيوعيون من هذه الفعله
لا يمكننا ان نستغرب ان تزيد النسب
بالاضطهاد وما قد يحدث في في المدارس وفي
مستقبل
هذه البلاد لابد من وقف هذا الامر مباشره
والان يقال
بان الامور وصلت الى طريق يصب معها
معالجتهم
وكافه الجرائم التي اقترفتها اسره بايدن
سوف اعينوا مدعا خاص
وكافه الاخرين المتورطين في تدمير
الانتخابات والحدود والبلاد انهم يدمرون
بلادنا وعندما سوف تتم عاده انتخابي وسوف
يتم اعاده انتخابي سوف افعل ذلك
وسوف اقوم بالتدمير
الدوله العميقه ونعلم من هي الدوله
العميقه
يرغبون
بانتزاع حريتي وانا لن اسمح لهم بانتزاع
حريتكم يرغبون باسكاته ولكنني لن اسمح لهم
ان يكتموا اصواتكم وانا الشخص الوحيد الذي
يستطيع انقاذ هذه البلاد لانكم تعلمون
انهم لا ياتون
من اجل بل هم سوف ياتون من اجلكم لكنني
سوف اتصدى لهم
في في الخمس من نوفمبر
204 وعشرين سوف تاخذ العداله مجراها وسوف
نقوم بجعل امريكا عظيمه مجددا شكرا جزيلا
فل ويبارك الله بكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]